This is a building, in a town, on an island,
in a territory, in the South Pacific—an
ocean so vast that barely any planes transverse
it; barely any ships sail through it; an area
so empty that when we talk about how many
people live where we look now, we do not talk
in magnitudes of billions or even millions,
we talk about the mere thousands of people
who live in this immense precinct of our world.
But in a territory, on an island, in a town,
in these buildings live just fifty of them.
Fifty people, on an island, where the only
way in or out is on a boat that comes a few
times a year.
These people live hundreds of miles away from
the closest other people, thousands of miles
away from the closest city, and ten thousand
miles or sixteen thousand kilometers away
from their country’s capital in London.
That’s because this is Pitcairn Island—Britain’s
smallest, furthest, and most isolated overseas
territory.
These fifty people live a life so removed
from those of Belfasters or Edinburghers or
Cardiffians or Londoners that believing that
they’re part of the same country is just
as hard as believing that Pitcairn itself
even exists.
That’s because to all rational minds Pitcairn
shouldn’t exist.
It just doesn’t make sense for there be
an island of fifty people living in the UK
yet on the absolute extremity of earth.
That’s why I sought to make sense of it.
In the first season of our new podcast, Extremities,
I explore over six episodes why and how Pitcairn
exists—why people settled there, why it
became part of the UK, why people still live
there, how they get there today, how they
get food, how they make money, how their government
works, how they communicate, how they plan
to continue existing, and much much more.
You can find Extremities on all major podcasting
apps, at ExtremitiesPodcast.com, or links
are in the description.
This is just season one and in future seasons,
we’ll be exploring why and how other of
earth’s most isolated settlements exist.
This is something I and others have been working
on for a while so I do hope you give at least
episode one a listen.
I believe it’s something any Wendover Productions
viewer will enjoy so I can’t wait to hear
what you think.